hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game between Magnus Carlsen and the
ali reza furiosa from round 8 of the
2018 blitz world championship ali reza
is currently leading the world blitz
championship he's at one point ahead of
everyone else across and is a one point
behind the leader who is ali reza and
it's really a wonderful game we're not
gonna overanalyze it as it is a blitz
game but it's it's a it's a very nice
game to show as always I had a wonderful
three days of the rapid water
championship now he's leading the world
blitz championship and now the test upon
tests the Magnus Carlsen himself so
let's see how this game went and it
features a very rare moment where were a
world champion misses a a well known
checkmate but that's why you are here to
solve the mystery so let's check it out
see for Mike Ross on the English opening
we have g6 g3 Bishop to g7 Bishop to g2
and the knight to f6 preparing the
castle
nice to see three if you Rosia castles
we have Knight to f3 and now d6 d4 by
Carlsen we now transpose into the Kings
Indian defense the the fiend ghetto
variation nice to see six and now comes
castles by Carlsen e5 offering a trade
in the center and Colson goes for it we
have pawn captures and now D captures on
e5 which is a very nice moment as the
young gentleman at the Grand Master from
Iran says that he does not mind trading
Queens so early against Magnus Carlsen
especially in a blitz game Crossing goes
Bishop to g5 simply continues developing
now he offers the trade which would then
go in White's favorites then white would
bring a rope into the game without
spending time but if you Rosa does the
same Bishop to e6 and now cross and goes
for Queen to a4 and this is nothing new
all of this has been played our plenty
of times before
and now Queen to b8 we have Bishop
characters tongue b6 by Carson on f6
Bishop captures on f6 and now nice to d2
again a well known plan that was used to
bring this Knight over to d5 to take
hold of the d5 square or to transport
this Knights to b3 to c5 and then as the
bishop is already occurring that b7 pawn
to make
a target and unknown move in this
position was Bishop to e7 to take
control of the c5 square but here if
eros agos Bishop to g7 and now it's a
new game from move 12 okay rook after
the one cross and brings the rook to the
open file roof to d8
fill Rosa does the same and now nice to
be three going for this night to c5 to
the pressure to b7 idea Knights the d4
by fury and now comes Knights to c5 and
here already
it's only more 15 but furiosa has a lot
of problems to solve your pawn is under
attack here and also e3 is coming and if
this Knight moves you're gonna have a
hard time defending against rook
captures in Knight chapters from b7 and
also night capturing this Bishop is not
really pleasant for black as you will
have your pawns double here
so first c6 not allowing wife the
capture on b7 and now comes a e3 forcing
the knight back and now if you play
Knight to a5 simply go back with the
Knights it then comes a nice captures
pawn captures and after c5 you can go
94-96
the the tension in the center via the D
file I will always favor white white end
with this rook undeveloped on the 8's
Peter like I said it would be
positionally lost game for white and
against magnus carlsen it would be a
loss game however you play it so okay
after e3 if you lose the decides to give
up some material as it is a bliss game
he's a very young player you know always
crushing that puzzle rush so push up to
g4 attacking the rook on d1 cause and
immediately snatches a night
it captures on d4 we have Frank after
sandy for attacking the knight Knight 3
to 4 and now Bishop captures on d1 rook
captures on d1 and now you can see that
cousin has two knights for the rook but
until this a a true gets into the game
it's really just a huge positional and
material advantage for Carlsen Queen to
c7 developing the Queen also trying to
bring the other rook into the game and
now comes Queen to b3 attacking the b7
point b6 defending and now comes Knight
to d3 as the knight is attacked here
rook 88 and now comes c5 and c5
is really such a nice move creating an
outpost for this night on d6
and if black captures which was played
in the game by fury then comes Queen to
see for now the CC pawns are excellent
targets we have Queen to a5 and now Nike
chapters on c5 and okay Bishop to f8
with a double attack against this night
but now B for protecting tonight also
comes with an attack on the Queen Queen
to a3 and now comes Knight to e5 an
excellent move and now you can see that
there is no possible way for Fuhrer to
actually defend the f7 pawn so okay he
tries Queen captures on b7 but now comes
Queen captures on f7 by Carlsen King to
h8 and now Queen to f6 check King has to
go back or Bishop has the block furiosa
blocks with the bishop and this is the
not critical moment as White is winning
however but here across and plays Queen
to g5 and it's still a winning game for
Magnus but it's a bliss game both of
them are low on the clock Pharaohs edge
is much lower on the clock to tell you
the truth but there is a much simpler
way to ended this game so since cousin
was you know in element in blitz you
know you don't wanna I don't know I feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find the the instant win Carlsen missed
you know I'm just gonna have a nice sip
of water so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations you are an
excellent fight finder of smothered
mates and for those who just want to
enjoy the shown Knights to f7 check is
the idea
King g8 and now comes Queen to e6 and
now there is no defense you're either
gonna suffer severe material loss after
Knight captures rook with check or if
you try anything let's say Queen
captures here then we get the good old
since modern mate Knight f6 a double
check if you go here then Queen to f7
checkmate if you go there then you get
the wonderful Queen g8 check rook
captures and tonight to f7 and this will
be a excellence modern mate on the other
hand after Queen to e6 if you don't play
something like Queen captures here I
should try Bishop too afraid to make
some room for King then you're just
gonna suffer severe material loss Knight
characters with check King moves and now
whatever 25 check King will move and now
Knight captures on c6 everything is
and just you know measure up to d5 a
huge threat
there's no way to period there should be
five check and now King f8 Queen H it
will be checkmated the D scores are
covered just a wonderful idea all
together now but ok Crossin plate Queen
to g5 and now comes Luke to e8 as at
least the check on f7 will not come with
losing the rockin d8 Knight captures on
c6 by Carson now the Queen and on b4 and
also the broken b8 are under attack so
it's not all that better Queen to c4 and
now comes Knight captures on b8 now we
have Queen to e2 threatening the rock on
d1 but here cross and simply retreated
with the Queen Queen to d2 and it was in
this position that Alireza
oh it is a few rosa who was leading the
tournament by a full point resigned to
the game he resigned due to a severe
material disadvantage and there is no
point in Canadian Plus Carson was much
much better on the clock but yeah a very
interesting moment this Queen to g5
opposed to Knight f7 check and ok most
likely if Carson didn't find any other
way to continue he would have played
knight of seven but still it's just very
interesting as the official commentator
speed of like when meters Nietzschean
curving any were extremely surprised it
was like a war moment that Carson did
not play this but yeah such is Blitzen
you know anything can happen so that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos your think all for watching and I
will see you soon as I'm now going to
continue enjoying the the World
Championship
thank you all and I will see you soon